Наш шеврон - військових ЛГБТ. Герб України та єдинороги - це символ ЛГБТ,
яких нібито не існує у Збройних силах. Ну, і відзнака "Учасник бойових дій" - ветеран війни.
Мене звати Владислав Мірошниченко, мені 24 роки. Родом я з Луганська.
Учасник війни на Донбасі. І я відкритий гей.
Я відкрився спершу друзям. У мене з'явився доступ в інтернет,
я став багато читати, побачив, що в історії дуже багато таких випадків,
що це нормально, ці люди нічим не відрізняються, і я перестав себе знищувати.
До цього я почав зневажати себе - через те, що я якийсь інший, що у мене,
можливо, трошки інший характер. Тому що батько хотів, щоб я такий "мужик" був,
"пахав" у шахті - мовляв, це найбільше, що може зробити чоловік.
Він побачив смайлик у мене в телефоні, коли я його відправив хлопцю,
з яким познайомився - він був такий самий, як я, я хотів з ним поспілкуватися.
Там був просто поцілунок. І він дуже негативно на це відреагував -
хотів мене і в армію відправити, і в інтернат.
Мати спершу сказала, що я це переросту. Потім вона теж почала читати книжки.
Я потім став більше їй відкриватись, і у нас налагодились відносини.
У коледжі я став більш відкритим, тому що я навчався в більш поінформованому колі людей,
ми займалися програмуванням, працювали з комп'ютерами,
це були люди вже зовсім іншого покоління.
Коли це була підконтрольна Україні територія, я був відкритий.
Але коли почалася окупація, стали людей знаходити, саджати,
деяких вбивати, катувати - я просто почав закриватися в самому собі.
Тобто я став, як всі інші - я став сірою масою, з опущеною головою, став зневажати себе.
Коли я приїхав на підконтрольну Україні територію, побачив наші прапори,
в мене просто розгорнулося серце, тому що я знав, що я вже вдома -
я можу спілкуватися мовою, якою мені хочеться, я можу слухати музику,
яка мені більше подобається і за гімн України мене не будуть вбивати чи карати.
В ЗСУ я вступив у 20 років. Я матері нічого не казав, вона про це не знала
весь час моєї служби. Я казав, що працюю в лісництві.
Я служив у 43-ій окремій артилерійській бригаді. Був командиром "Піона" -
це великокаліберна артилерійська система. Ми якраз були відведені за Мінськими угодами,
але були готові до наступу, були готові захищати наші позиції.
В ООС я знаходився близько року, може, навіть більше. Служив я три роки.
У мене була депресія в армії. У мене стався розрив з хлопцем,
тому що я не міг з ним спілкуватися, я не міг з ним зустрічатися.
Перед командирами, побратимами я не міг навіть спілкуватися телефоном.
І тому я почав спілкуватися в мережі, знайшов групу ЛГБТ-військових.
Віктор Пилипенко сказав, що він теж військовий, що він теж відкрився,
і зміг витягнути мене з цієї депресії.
Зрештою я наважився відкритися повністю.
Тоді я поговорив з командиром. Він спитав, навіщо це мені потрібно -
мовляв, я можу і так жити. Але я казав, що не можу брехати побратимам,
я не можу бути не самим собою, тому що я вже жив таким життям в окупації
і з мене досить. Якщо я буду мовчати, я просто вб'ю самого себе.
І я відкрився.
По-різному люди стали ставитись до мене. Деякі більше стали спілкуватися зі мною,
а деякі зовсім відштовхнулися, але говорили більше за спиною.
Тільки одна людина сказала мені, що вона зі мною щось зробить,
якщо мене зустріне, або сама приїде та знайде мене.
Мої товариші мені дзвонять, багато з них зараз служать, деякі запрошують мене в бригаду,
кажуть: приїжджай, вертайся.
Вони мене підтримують.
Коли мені зателефонують з військкомату, або я просто побачу,
що відбувається гаряча фаза, я готовий з побратимами, з хлопцями з ЛГБТ-спільноти,
які служили, повернутися на фронт.
Зараз у Києві ми діємо, щоб нам не довелося ходити так, як зараз ходять люди в окупації.
Україна - це свобода, наш герб символізує волю, і я хочу бачити
через десять років вільну Україну, де кожен громадянин буде вільним,
може бути самим собою.
Ту країну, в якій нам не доведеться ховатися, приховувати наші стосунки, почуття.
Де ми зможемо узаконити наші стосунки та бути рівними.